hey guys and welcome to the destiny to
PC release day livestream I'm chasidy we
have a special guest today
hutch is in the house thanks for coming
back no problem thanks for having me so
we're gonna play destiny - today we are
it's finally out on PC haha
it's only been out for an hour so we
just started so we're gonna jump right
into the game now we're playing on the
MSI 75 VR Titan because today's stream
is sponsored by MSI so we're gonna check
out destiny 2 on this brand new laptop
and we'll show off the laptop a little
bit later but first we're jumping right
in so we're not super far into the game
because it just went live an hour ago
but how does it feel how does it look
well yeah this isn't my first time
playing on Khan or on PC but playing it
like this it makes it feel like this is
the way that destiny was supposed to be
playing yes I've been waiting for this
like I didn't want to do raids until I
was able to play on PC because I felt
like I wasn't gonna help anyone unless I
had to keyboard in the mouse yeah I ran
through the raid one time but I decided
I wasn't gonna invest too much more time
after that until the PC bill came out
because I knew that this was what I was
gonna Mane on and I mean it just yeah
like destiny - on console and a destiny
one on console wasn't ugly or anything
like that but this is just it's so much
something else yeah and you can feel the
difference right away
mm-hm I don't remember this part when I
played it they the first time it's been
a while but it's creeping me out a
little bit so how much destiny 2 did you
play on console a firm out like some of
my friends went super super hard that
wasn't the case for me but I did go hard
for like a couple weeks like two or
three weeks like I said I played I
played the raid
but you said you didn't play the red no
I was like I'm gonna wait I feel like
you really need their for each other and
I just want to be to my face again so it
was like to be honest definitely was my
first like console shooter that I was
like playing a lot
no I didn't I was new to it so this is
me jumping in for the first time
destinies with destiny too and I loved
it
like I was playing non-stop for about
three weeks you don't say you don't do
you play a lot of fps in general area Oh
only on PC like I was playing a lot of
Killing Floor 2 last year and then I
jumped at the fortnight recently and
yeah a lot of funny I know you've been
playing a lot of that I can't stop I'm
glad that this game came out it's like
especially if I go on the road or
something like that it would be nice to
just be able to pull out my laptop and
and grind my character mm-hmm
you can't really do that before like you
could I guess you could take like your
Xbox your ps4 to uh people do I mean now
I haven't any switches I'd bring that
around but yeah I love three my gaming
laptop around with me yeah this as well
this thing is yeah now there's a it's
literally like two inches thick it's not
making any noise or I know either
it's not you look super quiet you'd
expect it to be billowing fan air
alright so what are we doing in the game
right now we're just progressing as far
as we can easy European dead zone this
is in Korea right this is in the
European dead zone and I don't remember
what we're doing chesty yeah it's for
sure since I played early campaign I
think we're meeting up to someone to get
and take the thing to someone else who
does something with the same usually how
these yeah
taking that these dudes so we're also
hanging out in the chat so we're on
gamespot we're on GameSpot YouTube
GameSpot switch and we're also cross
streaming to hutch his twitch channel so
hello to everyone there so if you've got
questions for hutch you got comments I
want to talk about destiny - you want to
talk about PC gaming whatever you want
to talk about please leave your comments
and questions and I will be monitoring
all four of those chats actually get my
chat in front of me I'm gonna try to be
but it's a little bit a little bit
trickier in this kind of a setting maybe
we can get in to play some PvP when that
unlocks I'm not agree I don't think it's
gonna happen in this stream we're here
for about 90 minutes but eventually I
want to get in on that all right we're
gonna I'm just gonna power through it
yeah it's gonna get through it as
quickly go through it reason please
write through I'm not very confident on
with PvP but PvP is also a challenge for
me especially because I was playing on
console and I was like I am no good
right PvP is always gonna kind of tough
for destiny this go gap is pretty high
and it takes a bit to get pretty decent
at it like that's why she could be at
time and I was never even close to being
as good as some of the other players I
definitely preferred just like jumping
into strikes with my friends that was a
lot of fun just like going around doing
public events and whatnot yeah trying to
get cool guns yeah I get more I get I
get more competitive when I play games
so like the PVD stuff is fun to me but
the sort of wit drew me in a little bit
more than that's that stuff like raids r
fun yeah it's a lookin but that's almost
that's still competitive in a way but
yeah I had someone in the chatter just
join asking if we're playing on a laptop
yeah GT 75 VR Titan its MSI's laptop
it's big we're gonna show it off a
little bit later with some b-roll but
yeah it's it's pretty dope this thing is
a 1080 in it which is pretty sick you
know what does it say what kind of
processor uh yeah and hold on it's also
got like the keyboard is the thing
that's most distracting to me right it's
so cool it's got the rapid mechanical
RGB keyboard and it's got Kirk to RGB
backlight control it's multi modes so
it's like lighting up and you can
actually adjust the lights to however
you want freaky
see what else 120 Hertz refresh rate and
a three millisecond response time panel
that's got g-sync yeah I wasn't
expecting to be bad quite like this yeah
laptops better scare them away
I don't even know what g-sync is but my
buddy John tells me it's awesome yeah
that's what I've read as well something
to do with that video it's something to
do with I don't know what is are you
looking it up I'm gonna look it up after
I check out the chat really quick let's
see we're checking out YouTube chat
we're checking out twitch chat see what
everyone's up to we are playing destiny
to you it's PC launch day that's why
we're playing and you can play this game
on blizzards battlenet desktop app if
you're wondering this has been a day
that a lot of people have been waiting
for a lot of people because I know a lot
of people that that that played the game
for like a day or two at launch mmm-hmm
bunch of streamers that mostly mostly do
PC stuff and then they just they stopped
because they knew they were just gonna
be
focusing on PC when it came out light up
so there's yeah there's been a lot of
hype for this and I'll be curious to see
if like a lot of these other big
streamers are these big streamers
continue to play the game after like a
couple weeks yeah it'll be interesting
people are asking standard edition or
digital deluxe we're playing the
standard edition but you can also get
the digital deluxe the standard edition
will set you back $59.99 Digital Deluxe
is $99.99 and it comes with a base game
the digital deluxe comes with the
destiny 2 expansion pass you can get
access to both expansion 1 and expansion
2 new storing machines co-op activities
multiplayer and a welcome new weapons
armor and gear and premium digital
content with the legendary sword
legendary player emo and a fall at
pirate themed emblem
IIIi didn't use a world like that I only
the first yeah I was playing with the
Warlock on console but sunsinger class
was deadly I don't know much about that
were Larkins um I think I've been when I
stopped playing on console like teeth so
with I was using Boyd water
um how was that working up right that's
fun
well I keep forgetting
like discovery out of users
you stand in these pools
it's cool plane over the increased upper
being a lot faster
it is kind of a bummer that there's no
cross play or cross a plant but those
are huge but I would be playing on PC
anywhere and I know a lot of my friends
are also playing on PC so I think I'm
fine with that
I get it likes I was like in the back of
my mind I was really hoping that they
would that they would let you share your
character between either ps4 Xbox yeah
like starting over as a grind for sure
but yeah I mean yeah so I have 3 hunters
I only played with a warlock so I'm
gonna use the opportunity to try hunter
supposed to go
weapons did you pick up yeah I'm just
picking it like an early game you
basically just pick anything that
anything you can get
you don't really hang on to the weapons
for longer than like one or two levels
usually yeah so no probably shouldn't
scratch the line
so now you've played a bunch of destiny
to on console how did it compare to
destiny one like what was your take I
mean it's it's a lot better it's hard to
put it into words why it's better like
they just done they refined their whole
system they simplified it it seemed it
looked prettier like the colors seemed
more vibrant on the PvP side like I know
a lot of people had problems with
switching before before but I really
enjoyed it like they made the maps a lot
smaller and then you know everything's
four before now instead of six v6 I used
to hate those big maps and the first one
because there would be
vehicles and tanks and it would take a
minute to get a copy so you don't have
to worry about that now but the only
thing with that with switching to four
before not the only thing but one of the
big things that people have been
complaining about is that team shotting
is just so important so it's really hard
to kind of lone-wolf it yeah if you lone
wolf it you'll chances are you'll run
into a team of three people holding some
corner and that frustrating a lot of
people but I really enjoyed it but yeah
the story is story better way way better
there is a story there's a story
yeah and Gul I just thought was such a
cool villain definitely I don't even
remember who the bomb was in the first
one I think the villain was yeah yeah
but I yeah I really enjoyed the campaign
and uh destiny - that was a lot of fun
yeah that's good it was really good but
I like the nonlinear approach too so
when it would kind of flashback back and
forth between Gul talking to this
speaker mm-hm
when he was chained up
yes wait what Oh destiny - destiny -
yeah yeah you kind of give me all right
we are at the farm indeed we are do the
thing and take a thing and take it to
another that bird is not glitching out
that's a good sign
did you run into that the first time ah
the bird flips out I think at the tower
got a good knot or not at the farm I
don't think I saw them it definitely
happened to me at the farm oh I remember
it happening to me at the farm
his name's Devlin look at her good guy
great shot
if you give them a hand yeah usually it
shows you what you're wearing and then
you were able to compare it does okay
alright we are hanging out in chat so
let's see if there are any questions on
YouTube or twitch and now oh I guess who
came let's jump right into that crucible
you're like I thought
we've barely done anything that's crazy
mr. incredible says why does Hotch have
hair or one last ride we'll see how it
goes
I don't think I have to do anything else
yeah skedaddle I'm not ready for the
crucible yet let's go know play a little
bit more let's get some guns all right
over on Twitch major game week said the
game looks great just don't want to buy
the game again that's understandable
I mean if yeah I bought it I bought it
because I want to play on PC I've been
waiting to play on PC so did you buy it
on console yeah okay mm-hmm
you just had to you wanted to yeah i
mean everyone else wanted to play too
and it was a really good opportunity to
just like bond with my co-workers and
bond with my friends and it was a lot of
fun I'm glad that I did and also I just
wanted to get into it cuz I've been
looking forward to that Gamgee now that
I've got your powers back yeah I know
this game would be a good like
team-building exercise I was playing
with a lot of co-workers here in the
office I was just like yeah go home then
go online and then see everyone there
and just we just join it party chat even
if we were in two different fire teams
we'd all be in the same party chatting
together you know what I just read was a
John Carpenter apparently has completely
lost his life to destiny too he's gotten
super interesting I don't know if it was
John Carpenter but I'm pretty sure it
was what do you but this is a new
information John Carpenter it might not
be him but I'm fairly certain it's him
and it was like an old-school like kind
of horror director got super oh wow I
think you're right John Carpenter is
dedicating his life to destiny but his
bizarre but awesome
all this is very fun game I wonder how
we got into it now front which the king
in yellow said is John Carpenter yeah
that's weird could you imagine like
you're playing and then you're you're
like up against John Carter's like oh
that's cool harder and then time
actually is what his name is probably
like J carp and whatever his birthday is
like his first aim screen press and hold
the tab alright let's do the thing we're
gonna go get a thing complete adventure
a new frontier weight loss sector was I
supposed to wait oh yeah the starting
point start adventure follow I guess we
go this way
seen any good movies lately
uh yeah Blade Runner day 20 49 you watch
that I just saw it again a couple yeah I
nearly cried the seconds cause it's and
it's such a pretty that's my favorite
movie so far this year for sure
definitely in the top three for me but
what's your what's your other top top to
get outs in there good for sure look
maybe Logan
oh goodness phenomenal
yeah I think is that Dunkirk and Logan
Dunkirk was incredible - oh boy alright
yeah no need really hard to figure out
my top ten this year 2017 is just been a
a good year for more easily waiting on
the star wars cute oh yeah just I'm not
very serious guys what does here that uh
Mark Ruffalo went to the premiere before
and was Paris spill things before the
movie and then I accidentally left his
periscope open and so streamed the audio
of for the first
[Laughter]
which I thought was perfect that is
really funny yeah they couldn't do a
planet horrible because I think
Universal odds are rights to that so
they for movia different weighted this
sector that yes must have put them here
and they're about the region as they
scouted around how's your chat doing
good they're asking if I got a DMCA
strike his periscope stream I don't
think I did oh no Jim and said hey do
you want to turn your freakin phone off
well at least it wasn't anything visual
that's amazing it is pretty funny
alright so if you're wondering about the
content rollout for destiny to the raid
will be available approximately one week
after released ritual so that gives you
some time this week to like level up and
gear up and then if you're wondering
about DLC it's confirmed that the DLC
and patches will come out at the same
time for every platform
wait so there they don't have the
exclusive thing with Sony now where the
the DLC would come out like a month
early maybe but I don't know it says
that it's confirmed that DLC in patches
will come out same time for each
platform so I'm gonna I'm gonna trust
GameSpot calm hey if you are just tuning
in we're playing destiny to its launch
day and we're playing on the PC launch
day for PC it's been out on Xbox one and
ps4 for a while but you can now play it
on PC and it just went live at 10 a.m.
Pacific time so we're pretty early on in
the game and we're playing on the MSI
gt70 v vr Titan yeah random random white
kitten in my chat yeah you can actually
you have a fo B slider right here it
goes up to 105 which is really nice and
I think it's 30 frames calf 60 frames
capped or or maybe it's 60 20 I'm not
sure but I think we're playing on 64 now
but this could this computer could
definitely we didn't mess with it enough
because this would suspect that this
computer has you can definitely run a
lot of potential here on caps framerate
get a Houston
what is your favorite old fart was my
favorite weapon just overall was that
Aaron well the thing was I think you
need to pre order to get it but you
probably yeah I at this point yeah oh
that was like oh like a laser yeah sure
yes and just like when you focus on the
enemy and just keep like shooting at
them then it just the damage gets more
and more and more why am i why am I so
under level
[Music]
no I remember doing exactly this when I
first started and it was extremely hard
and I had to like I think I failed once
I had to come back what's a skip
something
I think I've wandered around more before
I did this
get this definitely happen to me through
my first playthrough that captain took
me out
you all right how are we going doing and
twitch and YouTube
Bob Jones said Sony still has exclusives
i I tongue smacks and a strike
content gets released at the same time
across platforms bob was there a
recommended level for that captain yeah
I'm sure there I didn't say I think I
remember that for some rad magnetic free
says is this a rebroadcast he looks he
looks younger here whoa you're trusting
interesting Benjamin Button of gaming
well I appreciate that that's good I'm
getting old chasity yeah do you feel
like you're just deteriorating it's like
my back hurts I wanna go sleep I feel
like my like some skills haven't
deteriorated too much though keeping him
sharp man you keep him sure I guess yeah
I remember it like people people telling
me you know once you get into your 30s
or something like that you're just your
reaction times not gonna be as good I
feel like I'm at the peak of my game
right now there you go yeah
[Music]
all right so let's see what's going on
on the YouTube chat
we are playing destined to on PC launch
day someone asked what's the size of the
the screen on this laptop do you have
that information I think it's pretty it
looks like it's probably like 20 to 24
inch 25 inch I'm sure a safe bet I will
find out for you
and check out I'm gonna type into the
chat and see how to go Dylan
am I supposed to oh I think I needed to
go talk to that guy
so you still in the same mission are you
gonna go back or are you gonna do
something else and I have to this guy
yeah maybe you guys are right maybe it's
not quite 24 it's just I might do don't
know what it is I guess I would be
pretty massive yeah perhaps if you were
a mite quicker right the beacon while
you were tussling with a fallen we've
encountered a bit of a setback Hawthorne
has placed the last relay on the
mountain okay
maybe 17 inches probably 15 inches
j15 my incredible mod says it is
seventeen point three inches according
to according to their their website but
I don't know if you guys can see it
though but like it is like the thickest
base of a laptop I think I've I've ever
seen a bird or 2 inches it's dirty
yeah and that fans finally kicking in
here but mhm don't really hear it that
much no I don't think they can hear it
at all I would scream too with gaming
laptops they're pretty loud all the time
alright on twitch major gamer geek said
17-inch called it nice job Guardian
friend is on roots I'm getting too old
to clean up after you so Rio can yell
said I'd love to see PvP at 60fps yeah
let me I'll play through this mission
here and then hopefully get a gun I can
once
it was great a lot of fun know if I'm
under love yeah yeah it's a challenge
I want to see like slides around want a
hipfire a lot more when I play with a
mouse and keyboard and it doesn't you
feel like you don't really get penalized
for it doesn't seem like there's any
kind of accuracy
[Applause]
so you can also play this with
controller yeah it's really a preference
thing now it's just like putting the
controller and just kick back or you can
I think I might actually play with the
controller yeah when I yeah when I'm
home with my setup and everything like
that I think I'll probably end up doing
it that way way that they do that like
that the way that they balance the PvP
is I think you get a generous amount of
aim assist if you use a controller on PC
whereas if you're playing with a mouse
of keyboard you don't you know obviously
don't get me a masseuse anything like
that but I had some some friends that
were playing on PC versus people that
were using a mouse a keyboard while
using a controller and yeah avengers' of
the highest order
on YouTube Ella McFlurry said what's the
price for the game and is it out right
now yes it's out now it just went live
at 10 a.m. Pacific time and the standard
edition is $59.99 and you can get that
on blizzards
battlenet desktop that what do you think
of it being on
yeah makes sense all right it's a it's a
it's a clean interface you know I've
never really had ten of the problems
we've got on that would have been it
would have been surprising thing if they
put it on Steam I think okay
all right check your chat there rowdy
boys we're hanging out on YouTube and
twitch on gamespot switch and Hutch a
switch so hang out and ask some
questions talk about whatever you like
talk about destiny to you what are you
guys playing let me know in the chat
right now let's see what kind of
questions we got so it sounds like
someone got planning that you had to ask
that now we're not selling the game
today so someone just legitimately asked
if we're selling anything
no they said sounds like someone got
planning the chat to ask how much the
game was tell hutch I love him lovely
woman I loves you Turks boy said hey
hutch how are you and is this game worth
getting I'm doing really good I said a
nice family trip all right yeah you're
in town to see some family and sleepy
yeah so that worked out yeah yeah
definitely this game is a lot of fun if
you like um if you like first-person
shooters and you like loot loot style
games like Diablo of Borderlands I think
it's a pretty safe bet that would a good
way to pass the time a lot of it a lot
of the activities are not too intense so
you know I actually really enjoy the
grind
sometimes the doing the tedious stuff is
really rewarding not that this game is
super tedious but the grind in general
is there's a lot of fun yeah I've lost
many many hours I think of destiny to
use a really great way to get into
destiny like I don't think you need to
have played destiny 1 in order to enjoy
destiny - that was my experience cuz I
didn't really play destiny one at all
and destiny 2 has was like a huge part
of my month of September all this thing
was far from perfect - so like this you
know they did a really good job of
tuning the grind so that it's you know
it takes it's a lot of work but it's not
as repetitive the first part
yeah and the first one you'd have to
you'd have to farm these materials like
helium filaments and mm-hmm
I can't remember the other like if you
wanted to upgrade some of your guns or
if you want to do to accomplish certain
tasks so you needed these resources and
you have to go to like the moon base or
Mars or whatever and then just run
around for like two hours just
collecting their resources which is it
got real I mean that was bad it's pretty
time-consuming I'm just typing something
and so far in this game they don't
really have anything that's quite on the
level of that that's good
and so we are playing through the
campaign right now if you're just tuning
in we are playing destiny 2 on the MSI
gt70 5 VR Titan and we're gonna check
out more of the laptop a little bit
later Brook hutch is here and he's
playing and you've been doing it on the
PC version seems you've really kicked
the Hornets oh it's the laser trap you
can just shoot walk under that I kind of
enjoy the laser traps oh I think the
last time I was here the Star Wars
trailer had just dropped like that that
morning that's right I think that was
one of the first things I said to you
I'm like would you did you watch the
second trailer did cuz we had to break
it down for GameSpot universe yeah but
yeah it was it was good um I think
there's a lot of misdirection on that
because otherwise it just seems really
spoilery especially the um I don't want
to spoil too much but let's not spoil
anything the the kylo I think you know
thing goes I think scenes are caught up
to seem like they're lying up exactly
but they're they're not if they really
left that in there and that happens and
that happens one to one in the movie
I'll be pretty disappointed yeah first
I'll be mad that they showed it in the
trailer Thor did a really good job of
not giving away too much black panther
did a good job of not giving away too
much spider-man gave away like Oh every
major action set piece in that film
there wasn't one that was that wasn't in
the trailer mm-hmm which is like to me
it's like it's what they're doing with
trail
these days is a big problem I'm not
trying to avoid them unless I have to
watch them for work which is usually but
power must be yeah they have a way way
too much justice we did a better job I
feel like I don't know too much about
Justice League which is good like it's
very big
are you worried about that movie
anything to the art I think it's gonna
be fine I'm gonna walk on back that was
fun I think that's that's going to be my
takeaway okay I don't think it's gonna
blow my mind but I think I'd be fine
well joss whedon coming in that's
certainly gonna change things
definitely is but who knows how much was
shot and how much he had left to work
with and how much he reworked yeah I
don't know I want to believe okay I also
want to believe really good it's good
either don't or good odds but you do
pronounce it to you I think it's good
joke I wasn't crazy about Aquaman dude
relax
oh man I think I think it's a good look
but I kind of hyped for Aquaman more so
than I am for cyborg or flash seems like
one - yeah he's a piece of fun and I
care - I like him
but there's there's just like a little
too much boys I like that the trailers
are just like Aquaman riding on things
or Aquaman like being carried by someone
I can fly
[Laughter]
alright are you guys gonna be playing
destiny 20 seas talk to me in the chat
tell me what you're looking forward to
about playing on PC or what you're
looking forward to about DLC I bet you
guys have played a lot of destiny to you
so far you know a lot of people might
you have been waiting I bet I suspect
many of you guys are gonna be hopping it
today
I got a drive home I wanted to get a
character at least up to life 20 yeah
the end of the day but I don't think
that's happening Tycho bucks at what
difficulty you're playing there's
difficulty settings like for the strike
since I Luna I used to think about the
cat from Sailor Moon you know about
Sailor Moon
pretty sure she has a Sailor Moon tattoo
yes that is correct
for context I am friends
that did it you think the servitor
brought the power back off
I just just don't question on twitch
from goob how did you bind your key
mappings I haven't gone in and messed
with it I'll do that when I get when I
get home mm-hmm
what do you think you're gonna do oh
there's a lot of macros there's a lot of
like actions in this game so that's
gonna be that'll definitely be something
that'll take a minute to like to tune to
get in there and just mess around mm-hmm
but yeah sure I got a dog at home with
like 12 macros on the side so oh wow
let's check back in with YouTube
Chris Burton us can't choose between
this shadow of war or a/c origins what
would you guys recommend who I haven't
touched shadow war and I yeah sounds
great feel like I feel like if you
haven't played destiny to yet and you
were waiting for PC play destiny to you
already like it's it's a lot of fun yeah
I would pick that but yeah I think
you're probably gonna get more bang for
your buck you could easily put 1500
hours and characters yeah and I feel
like it's not it wouldn't be too
terribly difficult if you don't have any
like why are all friends to have a game
I don't think it would be too tough to
to find some reddit forum or thread or
something like that and pick a fireteam
that way yeah they make it a lot easier
in destiny to from what I'm hearing yeah
but I haven't played any Assassin's
Creed origins yet so I wouldn't know
whether to recommend that or not but our
reviews coming up but I played a little
bit of shadow of war and it was fun like
it's it's fun to like interact with all
the different like orcs and all the
differently or captain's but I got a
little bit bored yeah like it's fun it's
just I think the problem is they're way
too many good games right now and I'm
prioritizing right now so like it was
just kind of low in my list I played it
for work and then I kind of fell off and
I'm gonna jump back and definitely to
today and then a lot of games coming
crazy day it's got its got Wolfenstein
Mario and Assassin's Creed origins so
something for everyone I'm really
looking forward to Mario yeah yeah
because I thought I thought Super Mario
Galaxy was amazing
and this one is like the the spiritual
successor to that right essentially like
there's um our reviewer said there's
like a bunch of like different moons
like there's just so much there's it's
so packed so good I can't wait to check
out the game like it was worth it to buy
a wii just to play super mario galaxy
I'm really yeah I was a little sad with
my wheel I didn't do much on it Oh new
Super Mario Brothers was fun on the Wii
U but and I think did they have did they
did they make galaxy 2 for Wii U or for
Wii I don't remember I think is we the
first we didn't play it just kill
are you going to be playing Cod World
War two oh yeah lots and lots and lots
yeah yeah I have something kind of cool
to announce around that in the next
couple days here I'll let you guys keep
it lots of touches twitch yeah there are
you a big big card person I am NOT no no
I I have never played Cod I know I've
played it I've never played it on a
regular basis I will be checking out
World War two too many games you know a
lot of people that don't play that don't
that don't play Cod still like to play
stuff like zombies so might be fun for
you to zombie sounds cool
yeah zombie sounds a lot of fun I should
just go to the bar what came to you guys
playing listen on the chat right now or
what are you looking forward to playing
this week there's a lot happening man
I'll tell you what though for tonight we
were talking about it before the stream
started and not that is a fun game well
that game has disrupted my life like I
wake up craving that game I'll go to
yeah especially when you're playing is
for a lure - yeah I'll wake up and like
like I'll try to go to bed at like
midnight and I'll just have too much
energy I'll just go and play that game
for three hours you know it's pretty
rare that a game does that and yeah you
could totally get sucked in for hours at
a time
god it's so fun it's really fun it's fun
soloing it's fun with the team - I don't
know why I came here there's a lot of
Wolfenstein hype in your chat
Wolfenstein hype says mr. incredible oh
nine will design and Mario says random
white kid and wolf it's signed to you
and GA Alpha Wolfenstein mine to your ex
I played a little bit of Wolfenstein the
new order is that was called and then
their expansion I played just like a
little bit not too much and it was fun
they make good games over there
that's why I was so hard I didn't switch
out my armored stuff how do i dismantle
scavenger City Wolfenstein 3d I think
was like the first first person shooter
right mm-hmm
I'm fairly positive it was the first fps
of all time
all right so let's see Oh Jason
McMillan's of the new South Park game
did you get to play that yes I'm Ivan
touchy I'm not a big turn based shooter
guy or turn-based game can be tarnished
what is this game what what happened in
South Park so I think this gun the
pariah I think that that's actually
pretty decent in PvP so maybe we'll jump
in there do it see how that gives I've
been watching as we play a little bit of
it and it is it was really funny yeah I
don't know how they do I think the only
reason that they get away with some of
the stuff that they get away with is
because they've just been doing it for
so long it's their thing and everybody
expects it from them but if you were
like a new show or a new property trying
to it would be really hard to get the
green light from like their studio 2017
yeah I don't think South Park would have
yeah they get away with a lot there's
that one aspect of that game that I want
to talk about but I can't because it's
like so over the line oh my god alright
so before you jump in let's show off
this laptop this is a really good time
to show off our MSI gt70 v vr Titan so
let's cut to that b-roll there it is
it's got up to you GT X 1080 graphics
card a new rapid mechanical RGB keyboard
that keyboard is so cool it has right
perky RGB backlight control with multi
modes it has 120 Hertz refresh rate and
3 milliseconds response time panel
available g-sync is also available and
the starting price is two thousand six
hundred and ninety nine dollars and it's
available on Newegg and amazon so that
once again is the GT 75 vr Titan and now
we're gonna jump into the crucible we
are I'm just gonna talk to your chat
anyone I'm trying to get them to ban
someone for me oh I think you already
got it
they're on it
sometimes sometimes they don't respect
women in the chat then sometimes it yeah
banhammer we respect women at the stream
you guys so let's just knock it off it's
just one guy there's one guy who comes
in and like says some nonsense every
time but I died I never want to ban him
because I feel like if you ban someone
that on some level they win you know
it's a toss up but sometimes sometimes
you just got to drop the banhammer it's
totally fine
I don't think I'm gonna do very well in
PvP oh we're a very low level right now
level four yeah and I don't even think I
have like a like a like a nade I don't
even think I have a grenade yet or do I
you possibly do go ahead and check out
your stats right now you don't know I
haven't even upgraded this I don't think
Oh three points oh I haven't it there
you go yeah you're fine that's the one I
want eventually do an upgrade man I want
both yes yes you do
okay we got the healing rift strafe
glide and with the green I do you have
straight I think the straight line is
better for for PvP do you want that
fireball grenade yeah we'll stick with
this one for now and then we'll switch
to that one when we get to level 5 cool
so we are gonna jump into the crucible
if you're just tuning in we're playing
destiny 2 on PC release day hutches here
across streaming all sorts of places his
twitch our twitch YouTube so leave your
comments leave your suggestions
tell us what games you're playing tell
us what you think of destiny to you on
PC or if you're going to be playing on
PC so did you say you were gonna be
picking up Odyssey yes I put her in it
so I am waiting for that to show up yeah
I'm really happy with the switch man we
got it like a month ago it's it's a
really solid little little console they
got over there great for travel great
yeah fantastic Mario karts a lot of fun
as we got super into that Mario Rabbids
game and then there's one other one yeah
breath of the wild is definitely up
there those guys make me feel so dumb
like an hour on this one like little
mini temple oh just like trying to
figure out there was the one for you
where you can just turn it upside down
and I was like wait a minute I've been
trying to figure this out because oh
yeah there's one where you have to like
tilt the the switch yeah
like guide like a ball through a maze
and I think I want to talk about where
you turned upside down I think that's
what same one no that was a pain in the
ass the thing that you were it's like a
maze that you roll the ball through
right yeah but I would just I didn't
turn upside down oh oh not the platform
I don't remember
anyway I played I played press little
wild on a Wii U because I needed to
justify pick purchase I was like before
I get a switch I at least play one game
on this yeah it's not going as terrible
as I thought I got I already got one
kill so we you know I don't know nothing
PC games mannered tough yeah playing a
playing competitive guy castling on PC
it's like there we go alright let's see
what's happening over on twitch and
YouTube don't pick up the heavy they
picked it up don't be long it's gonna
get those zones back
yeah like people hyped for Mario in the
comments
another Wolfenstein fan
I just won't aim down sights I think is
the way it is you don't need to be fine
yeah
numbers gosh Oh
this gun is incredible what is this
I don't know it's great detail up
so the nice thing right now is that
everyone's just starting out because
this game just went live yeah I mean
some people have that natural skill you
know there's they're good already are
you implying that I don't know you know
you're definitely good doing better than
I would thank you appreciate that you're
doing very well lost weight was us which
how about you what a weapons did you
like using in the console version um
pulse rifle is you know really strong
and the ARS are pretty strong a lot of
people are saying yeah I was having
trouble with the hand cannons on console
so I'm will probably try them out on PC
eigh I can't wait to see what you do
with that
don't see oh yeah they could through the
grenade launchers in this game are
really bad
caPSURE how's your team doing you guys
capturing yikes I'm not sure bring up
the scoreboard
GUP said hank hands on pc gotta be nuts
yes that's what people said during the
on the pc beta was that the hand cannons
were really really strong Jana said
hutch has skill but don't ask him to fly
in space the return of drainin
price there's only a few decent Ned
launchers but they are generally there
are generally better power weapons for
sure yeah give me a shotgun or rockets
any day
yeah it's fun playing on a higher fov
though that's one thing that I wish
distracted that Doritos was on your team
but continue here
sorry was maybe it's nothing to do with
like performance on console but they
never let you adjust the fov slider on
oh my gosh so it's nice to to play it on
here when you can bump it up to 105
makes you feel like you're running
faster it's always a good feeling yeah
this
this looks great oh come on see how your
chats doing drayman's in both chats
great you gotta wanna drain drain and
said higher fov and FPS seems nice might
pick this up for PC in the end it's a
game changer for me personally it's a
game changer
some people insist that they can play
fine on on 30 frames shoot we're
first-person shooters but that's just
not
someone else said they also turned it
upside down and the Zelda puzzle but
she's right I turned it upside down on
my game so what do you know the thing in
the game I think the platform turned
upside down not the switch oh and then
you were able to just do it really
rolled off the back yeah cuz the maze is
on the top of it and the back is just
solid so you just turn that platform
upside down and the ball just rolls on
oh but I feel like it was way too easy
like I didn't I feel like I wasn't
exploiting anything I couldn't turn that
thing over I'm not getting I spent an
hour just just trying to do that and
then I ended up just turning it over it
was like wow okay I feel really dumb
I'm not gonna lie to you I stopped
playing that game after that frustration
I told you guys it wasn't gonna go well
in PvP just for the record it's tough I
think if I had like four or five hours
so just playing non-stop to get you
through it I think I would be okay but
the initial when you first jump in first
cuz a lot of the times you're playing
against players that never left PC ready
for playing PC games for like the last
like 10 15 years there's a immediately
way better than you yeah there's
hand-eye coordination with the laptop I
won't write the keyboard and the mouse
is just Charlotte and we are playing on
this really cool laptop I like looking
at the lights Wow go team I can't take
too much more Thank You sponsibility for
that but yeah alright are you gonna play
again what do you think no you want to
progress a little farther yes I would
let's get a little bit stronger but you
want just mark that as a victory I think
I got like three kills so yeah if you're
just tuning in we are playing for
another half hour it's destiny to
release day we've got hutch here this is
all sponsored by MSI and we're playing
on the MSI gt70 5vr Titan hashtag
sponsored so you said you you're running
off a gaming laptop from your setup but
you're thinking about investing in that
I I yeah I'm thinking about investing in
building PCA for Christmas we could help
them I think that's the plan yeah you
know I'm having fun on gaming laptops I
have had no problems on but I also want
to edit there to see other things
like I'm a machine like this with a 1080
and yeah this if you process are you
able to you'd be able to render videos
really that's actually charity and ships
to three it's cool that it's we are
ready to see a lot of like the oculus or
be to these five uh but the vive is my
favorite one
aqua is also cool but I get too dizzy
and he SPR he tried it is either try
then I'm pretty prone to motion sickness
buying never had any problems with the
vibe and oculus is like hit or miss
depending on the game I've only had one
experience on oculus where I had pretty
serious motion sickness was the way that
they moved in the game that's it was
like normally for them for most of the
games you just you can just teleport to
where you want to go and that's way
better yeah but when you're actually
using the stick in makes me sick yeah it
was really tough yeah is the way to go
when you're here to help work with your
environment where your surroundings to
figure out how to progress to the next
spot but just kind of floating around in
zero g he was really cool so something
that's other zombie game called
something sunrise Arizona yeah didn't
make me dizzy or anything like that
robo recalls super fun super hot it's a
lot of super hot is my favorite one
super hot it's great yeah they took a
really simple concept and turned it into
a really rewarding experience it's tough
to get by it's like dodging weaving yeah
I didn't realize it like if you move
your your control your ear your touch
controllers that it would speed it up
and then if you didn't move it would
slow it down almost like a I didn't
realize that that was a mechanic I know
you can you can set there just learning
this now so that's like okay I'm gonna
go play more superhot that's like a
whole thing that you have to do and I
didn't realize it but then as me started
playing and alright we are over on
YouTube and twitch checking out the chat
what was this place
pindy expresso what happens to ps4 and
xboxone editions now
well DLC is still gonna come out at the
same time and you can play whatever
platform you up but I'm switching over
PC I'm planning to and you were saying
that there's no more there's no more
time to exclusive stuff like everything
comes out at the same time that but I
think Sony gets an extra strike and
right map and something else every map
probably notice hi Dan Sony just came in
and swooped on xbox on like a bunch of
different games
I didn't get into PS touch play section
until PlayStation 3
[Applause]
[Music]
this is scaring me initially playing
this on the console and just getting way
too scared of the scary drawers they can
overwhelm you
[Music]
that'll be fine swinging under level
what did I skip I must have skipped
something
yeah that's what we're working with do
you want to use any of your upgrade
points here no not yet let's save it
through these guys here you think you
can do that and then down here you have
to be level eight as well we're halfway
there are we still love before
oh I don't get there yeah no not by the
end of this tree oh this is freaking
that's a good name for a I left in my
heavy
[Applause]
Brown parade said is this game worth
getting our should I stick to warframe I
don't know how somewhere more famous but
it's a lot of fun I think you should get
it
did you play the PC beta
yeah a little bit wait I think I would
talk to had like a strike yeah like one
strike
yes one strike one multiplayer map and
then one night yeah Kevin Sparrow was
asking how's the performance compared to
the beta the so when I play the beta the
performance was fine I didn't have any I
don't have any performance issues there
and there's I haven't dropped any frames
playing this once I mean we're not
screaming at the same time you're set up
so if you're streaming then you might
have to take your settings down but just
straight up playing it
Studdard right over the beta having any
issues no I didn't have any problems
I love that yeah the my leg feels good
very satisfying good
nearly all day
yes
oh they're so crazy
[Music]
running through this thing I did the
same thing on Khan time let's just skip
something I think you're supposed to set
up all the patrols on earth and then by
the time you do that you get to the
right level yes so they do it any way
you want I definitely did a bunch of
wandering around for a bit I got here
did a good job in this game of getting
you two so it's a very linear experience
but but they do it in a way that is like
a logical progression so they get you to
where they want you to be mm-hmm but
they do it in a way that is fairly
rewarding I agree
Bob Jones said your SMG is best for the
thralls yeah
get that about a half hour left in the
stream we're playing for destiny choose
campaign right now the game just went 11
PC at 10:00 a.m. Pacific time so you can
check that out now over on battlenet so
you're gonna play this game tonight yeah
I am sure because I've got two days I'm
definitely to play this her and I would
switch off between Mario and destiny to
you this weekend do you get advance copy
nope not me
they're pretty losses do we have a
couple copies for our reviewer and for
consoles but but not I I have
pre-ordered it that was one thing that
was the cool thing about working for a
gaming media company is when you get the
you games like a month in advance or
something okay
you get like streamers but the streamers
you get games usually like a couple days
in advance or a week in advance
it really depends what are you talking
well they didn't give me like a copier
that's cool yeah you take it for granted
after a while but like when you first
get into the industry
I don't think I'm gonna beat this part
which class is your favorite to play now
you're playing for luck right now but
yeah so I am either I've only played as
a Titan and destined to me
this part is tough so I can't comment I
hear that the hunter is good for PvP
mm-hmm and the other two classes are
better for PvE but I don't know I think
you guys are probably what does Chad
think what is your favorite class what
is the best class class if you're
starting out destiny to those settings
bricen all set hunter inspiring hunter
that's the best class what do you think
Bryce
jesus said tighten for life cease your
incredible 409 zat I like them all Titan
is a really good support class
that mini 8 said titan or warlock for me
yeah I'm looking forward to taking the
hunter to tip PvP because I hear really
good things about that
I only played as warlock on ps4 so all
by biased but I had a lot of fun things
were like on geez what happened suck man
Oh go set up some patrols yeah let's do
that
we've got 20 minutes so plan accordingly
okay what you'd like to do a major gamer
geek said warlock best class all-around
really that's the first time I've heard
that what makes a warlock so good tell
us major gamer geek what makes the
Warlock so good inquiring minds want to
know I mean I I also enjoy the Warlock
but I also don't know what to compare it
to yet cuz I haven't played titan four
hundred yet see now apparently on the
console build well I guess I'm I'm
assuming it's the same on PC but
apparently if you make three the same
class you don't get the same kind of
loot that you would get if you made one
of each class so so if you have three
hunters like a lot of the times like I
made three hunters I should beat the
campaign three times and cuz then you
can share all your equipment and then
you're just ready to raid right after
that but apparently that a lot of people
seem to think and I don't know if the
developers confirm this but a lot of
people seem to think that they dropped
the loot rate for your free character if
you if you're doing three of the same
character really so if you didn't get
this game it might be a good idea to to
make sure your if you're gonna run three
characters don't have them be three the
same don't make the same mistake that I
did which was honestly kind of
frustrating cuz I spent like a lot it's
like you know it takes like eight hours
to get through the campaign 15 extra
hours to invest all that calm is trying
to have it be
that's got a night not that seems a
little person yeah for sure
did you don't need to mention I those
livin and learnin major game II said a
warlock because of our craft Paulson
aids awesome in both PvE and PvP
you have to post an egg with the Titan
room I believe
should I try hunter or tighten it next
since I've only played warlock tightens
good yeah you can can heal yourself
pretty easily they have a one of the
abilities is if you get a kill with a
nail a it will refill your health so if
you're playing through the campaign solo
or something like that it makes it a lot
easier
[Music]
all right we're on twitch and youtube
and also on hutches twitch so I can see
all your comments if you got any
questions let us know
down there default edits a devourer
warlock is godlike
it's an upstairs
[Music]
Elian Garson I prefer hunters I don't
know who to try next I'm so torn please
tell me today the red Legion fighting
the fallen for a change
great idea I can extract archive audio
transmissions from any fallen in the
area where they said warlock is the best
class but Titans are a strong second
yeah from what I hear people kind of
universally say that the hunter is not
the best PvE class I don't know why that
is but that seems seems to be the
consensus from whatever from everybody
that I talked to all my pals already
said voidwalker using the devourer tree
that makes us
death call 26 it how much better is it
on pc than console it's so much better
yeah yeah it's yeah it's there it's like
a it's like playing it on a on a
Playstation 3 that's not an exaggeration
either like it really does feel like
this is how the game the limitations of
the concepts we're developing for but
it's it it fundamentally changes how you
play the game it changes how the aiming
feels changes how immersed you feel and
everything so yeah I mean it's it's a
big step up yeah there's what I've been
waiting for
mr. gamer geeks that hunter does not
have abilities to fire team and raids or
patrol like the other classes
interesting yeah yeah the hunters are
more about like DPS doing as much damage
damage as you can in the shortest amount
of time and then the other two classes
were more like Titan has always been a
support class I think over on hutches
twitch smash bet asked is there
cross-platform play no there is not they
are not planning to support unit sorry
oh I really expect like we were talking
on before the student really expected
them to do it at least with Microsoft
you're right I think it's because we're
playing off of battlenet not Xbox
anywhere yeah and there's no cross a
plant either so sorry about that
the bummer
if I rub here scary thought they're
gonna didn't borrow all these traps and
explosives and photos to good use
sowing chaos between your enemies ugly
idea
all the lasers go take a walk through
there oh yeah I thought this was full
auto
oh okay yeah
they'd like little areas where you find
kind of bosses big bosses oh I remember
this area being kind of a pain
yeah that's at earlier levels kind of
hard
Jesus Christ and the explosives
she's not not a shotgun I think there
are plenty left for you to scan Oh
I don't blame you for wanting to blow
everything up yes my deep scan will need
to be a deep deep scan though got it now
I can transmit these horribly dangerous
explosives wherever we need we man
destiny on switch would be something huh
something like 15 frames I mean one day
it's good so it's getting so much better
so much faster hmm you know why we had
to wait like 10 years growing up for the
from the jump from Super Nintendo to a
Nintendo 64 it wasn't it was much more
than that moves it was it felt like 10
years and the jump wasn't even that
substantial right now it's what a time
to be alive
Bob Jones said I wish cross-table of the
things so do we so to say me at work I
[Music]
gotta go home and play this again when I
get home - because after that long drive
great work broadcasting the message now
I decided to go with a marauder accent
hemostat move for publications actually
different let's keep the cherub Jones
really wants destiny on switch
make sure there's no whatever you said
spouts use eleven minutes left in the
stream so we're still I don't want to
crying through avoiding all these lasers
are you gonna everything just kind of
exploded our Fe yeah those lasers
everywhere this is gonna mean stuff like
if you try to if you try to do too much
without being punished here pay
attention I'd be on the lookout for drop
pods if I were you
all righty now what do you watch out for
the laser of those Oh like I had a
second ago I play a lot of video game to
describe unconventional
what
Oh
silence send these little things that
yeah
I wanna know
something that'll become obstinate a
minute oh I'm supposed to be down here
and it's so many lasers
Oh
now
Eleonora said don't blow things up use
them to kill your head
you think I mean I did
I could hear the explosions all the way
back here I bet it was quite a show
which means the fallen and red Legion
heard it too let's have another round
one clean up whatever's left great work
the good mouse - oh thanks this one
monkey said how'd you playing with a
touchpad no Susan the mouse if it looks
like I'm playing with I'm in trouble no
good
you guys check out the public event or
what do you feel like doing we have
about eight minutes left in this dream
is real quick alright so you want to
talk II I feel like we haven't talked
about the laptop enough actually someone
just asked do you master flash on your
twitch said what type of laptop is that
we are showing off the MSI gt70 v vr
Titan we can pull up that be role in one
more time since we're towards the end of
the stream let's pull up that b-roll
check it out
there it is that's the GT 75 VR Titan
and it has up to GT X 1080 graphics card
new rapid mechanical RGB keyboard with
perky RGB backlight control with multi
modes it has a 120 Hertz refresh rate
and 3 millisecond response time panel
available
it's got g-sync available and the
starting price is two thousand six
hundred and ninety nine dollars and you
can get it on Newegg or amazon that's
for the $20.99 for GT 73 with 1070
single card $25.99 for GT 73 with 1080
single card and yeah I mean this thing
is a suit like a seriously beefy
computer gaming laptops I've gotten so
much better in the last two or three
years you know yeah
like I'm fairly new to PC gaming I I
started two years ago and yeah I've only
been playing on gaming laptops because I
just bounced between different that's
what I did for a while too I had a
different gaming laptop for a long time
and then once I started building my own
and upgrading incrementally it really
kind of changed changed games helping me
spread the word for broadcasting a
signal from the farm to people who fled
the city saying you'll be safe here
got about five minutes left on the
stream we're playing destiny to you on
PC release day with hutch see if you got
any last-minute questions let us know in
the chat we're on hutches twitch our
twitch and our youtube yeah thanks for
having me out again
oh it's fast toast man exit I'm still
mystified by laptops that's powerful
you and me both dude it was it's
relatively yeah like that you can you
can get such a BP and not have it like
belong it's fan like a wind turbine the
whole time that's a big deal too
[Music]
stop following parents Ellis panels
defeated
three more there's two
eliminating that captain under the
church must have stopped coming we need
to make sure that signal is strong you
better hurry up and place that second
note here
it's kind of a hefty download for this
game it's like 36 gigabytes in normally
games are like 6 to 10 this is the first
time I've even seen anything since the
cabal hit us reach a clear location that
could be anywhere to keep us safe right
what did you think about the campaign
overall yeah I really liked it I really
liked it a lot the destiny in one
campaign was really not great so I think
that they do you think they took a lot
of the feedback and applied it I think I
probably already like I think when they
ship they probably knew that that was
the case because it like I think the
rumor was that they had this whole
fleshed out story and then they ended up
scrapping it was like 9 months left to
launch and some kind of revamped the the
campaign in the first one and it was
kind of rushed and it just wasn't really
robust was it really a real story but
with this one you can tell that they
were like well we don't want to make the
same mistake twice and so I've seen some
people have some issues with the
particulars of the story but overall I
thought it was way way better than the
first one much more compelling
going and how am I supposed to become
cell phone interference sterling device
destroyed so you have to mess with the
find the gambling devices
because a marker telling you to go that
way it's like to go please lenience
promo
thataway I think we remember there it is
yeah
see two more
we have about two minutes left
yeah what good things must come to an
end chastity I like that you can mantle
in this game - yeah nice little future
[Music]
looking for devices I think there's one
on the street somewhere that's telling
itself
yeah like the thing with that's that's
really nice about a free mention at the
front foot ever like a proper gaming
laptop is if you go on some kind of a
road trip or something like that you can
just bring your controller and be able
to play a game like this on the go yep
which is like this it this game tends to
attract people that really commit and go
hard so so that's nice nice to be able
to just play wherever you like yeah I
can't wait to play some strikes on PC
all right so we're gonna be closing up
our stream thank you guys for joining us
thank hutch thanks for being here thank
you so what do you think of the laptop
there are no performance issues
whatsoever and I'm playing on the
highest settings that's really that's
kind of like the only benchmark how does
it perform if you run everything on
ultra everything ran great let's I don't
have any complaints cool where can the
game start audience find you so they can
find me at twitch.tv and youtube.com
forward slash hutch and on Twitter if he
searches oh my god a touch you should be
able to find me there and yeah that's
kind of it cool thank you MSI for
sponsoring our stream and go ahead and
check out destiny 2 on PC bye guys
[Music]